طبيعه التهامي الان بدا المؤتمر الصحفي
للمدعي العام
من الدرجه الاولى وفقا لقانون ولايه يورك
هذه الجنايه
ارتكبها السيد ترامب بنيه ارتكابي جريمه
هذه هي فحوى هذه القضيه
34 افاده زائفه قدمت لتغطيه الجرائم اخرى
هذه جنايات وفقا لقانون ولايه نيويورك بغض
النظر عن من يرتكبها لا يمكن ان نسمح
بمثل هذا السلوك الاجرامي المتهم بشكل
متكرر كرر تقديم معلومات زائفه وحث اخرين
ايضا على القيام بهذا العمل
وادعاء المتهم بانه كان يدفع لماكل كاون
مبالغ
المصروفات قانونيه هذا بكل صراحه تزييف
وكذب وشهرا بعد شهر في 2000 حتى 2019
استمر في هذا باب ابريل مايو ويونيو حتى
بقيه العام لتسعه اشهر متتاليه المتهم
احتفظ بوثائق بيده فيها هذا التزوير بانه
كان يدفع لمايكل مبالغ مقابل مصروفات
قادونيه ووقع على شيكات شخصيا كدفعات
لماكر مكون مقابل هذه الدفعات على مدى
تسعه اشهر وايضا وجدنا 34 وثيقه تبين هذه
التزييف لماذا دون ترامب كرر هذه البيانات
الزائفه وهي محاوله
للتعتيم والتغطيه
جرائم لها علاقه بانتخابات 2016 وايضا
شركه اميد امريكا ميديا كوبرا
هارون اتفقوا في 2015
بان يوافقوا على خطه
لشراء وكبحي معلومات
سلبيه تؤثر في كسب صيد رمث للانتخابات
وكجزء من هذه الخطه دفع دار اخرون ثلاث
دفعات
لاشخاص زعموا ان لديهم معلومات سلبيه وهي
كادت من اجل ذلك تم تقديم افادات زائفه
اكثر ضمن السجلات الشركه الاعلاميه هذه
وهناك امراه اسمها ستار ميدانيا دفع لها
لتلتزم الصمت وماكل بعث ب130 الف دولار
لمحامي ستورمي دانييلز وكان هذا لاخفاء
معلومات مضره بسمعه ترامب عن الراي العام
هذه الخطه تنافت مع القانون تنافت مع
قانون الانتخابات وهي ترقى الى مستوى
التامر للتاثير في الانتخابات بشكل يتنافى
مع القانون
وايضا المبلغ تجاوز سقف المبالغ المسموح
بها قانونا وانتهكت قوانين ولايه نيويورك
لهذا السبب السيد ترامب قدم سادات زائفه
او ليس بامكانها ان يدعي بان هذه مبالغ
اعيد دفعها للسيد كون لانه دفعها
لو لانه اذا ما اعترف بذلك سيكون قد اقري
جريمه لهذا السبب
يقول انه كان يدفع للسيد في 2017 مقابل
اعمال او مصروفات قانونيه زائفه للتغطيه
على الجريمه
وفي احدى البيانات اواخر البيانات الزائفه
حاولوا حاولوا
تصنيف هذه
الدفعات على اساس انها موارد ماليه لها
علاقه بالضريبه
وطبعا اعتبر هيئه المحلفين الكبرى هذا
جريمه وفقا لقوانين ولايه نيويورك لان
الاحتفاظ بسلامه السجلات الماليه هذا امر
لازم في كل مكان وفي مقاطعه منهات في
لهذا السبب في
مقاطاعتنا
راينا سجلا وتاريخا في مثل هذه الجرائم
وايضا مكتبي ووجه عشرات التهم من هذا
النوع بتسليم في السجلات الماليه
والتزويرها
فهذه التهم نراها من احيانا في نظر البعض
كمصدر لكسب العيش ولكن الذين ينتهكون هذا
القوانين وجهنا لهم تهم عندما تعلق الامر
بالتغطيه جرائم لها علاقه بالجنس او
باعمال الصيرفه او انتهاكات للقوانين
الضريبيه في صميمي هذه القضيه اليوم هي
قضيه كما هو الحال مع قضايا اخرى مماثله
تتعلق
بمزاعم الكذب مره ت لتفادي القانون
ولتفادي المحاسبه وكما فعلت مؤسسه ترامب
المره
نحن اليوم علينا ان نلبي نداء واجبنا بان
الكل يبقى متساويا امام القانون بغض النظر
عن ماله او منصبه ولن يغير شيء من هذا هذه
الحقيقه